parole à marc laménie pour le groupe ump
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
la ministre de l'égalité des territoires
et du logement après six mois d'attentes
le rapport de l'inspection générale des
finances igf sur la mise en place de la
garantie universelle des loyers a enfin
été dévoilé malheureusement ce document
de travail indispensable à un examen
approfondi du projet de la loi allure
n'a pas été rendu public par le
gouvernement mais par la presse
cependant nous comprenons à la lecture
de ce rapport pourquoi le gouvernement
n'a pas fait preuve de transparence
celui ci est ri la mesure phare de votre
projet de loi
l'inspection générale des finances con
comme le conseil d'analysé économique
l'avait fait émet les mêmes critiques à
l'encontre de la garantie universelle
des loyers que celle formulée par notre
groupe lors de l'examen de ce texte en
effet pour financer notre dispositif
vous avez deux solutions
mais malheureusement aucune n'est la
bonne soit vous mettez en place une taxe
affectée mais comme le souligne lee gf
il y à un véritable risque
d'inconstitutionnalité
au regard du principe d'égalité devant
l'impôt
la création de cette taxe affectée
viendra donc s'ajouter à la trompe trop
longue liste des hausses d'impôts dont
le gouvernement s'est fait une
spécialité comme l'a rappelé tout à
l'heure notre collègue roger karoutchi
l'autre solution pour financer cette
garantie universelle des loyers c'est de
financer le dispositif par défaut public
aussi il convient de regarder la vérité
en face d'abord l'assiette des loyers à
garantir représente 50 milliards d'euros
lit gf alors a alors été clair si le
gouvernement ne revoit pas sa copie le
nombre d'impayés atteindra les 4 % et le
coût du dispositif les 1 milliard 500
millions d'euros
dernière preuve que le principe même de
la garantie universelle des loyers n'est
pas réaliste l'ijf propose noir sur
blanc dans son rapport d'exclure les
locataires qui ont un taux d'effort
supérieur à 40% vous le voyez bien mes
chers collègues c'est garantie
universelle des loyers est tout
simplement irréaliste et si d'aventuré
vous risquez à persévérer dans votre
erreur vous n'avez que deux issues soit
augmenter les impôts ou augmenter les
dépenses de l'état aussi laquelle de ces
deux ici allez vous choisir madame la
ministre je vous remercie merci madame
cécile duflot
monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur la garantie universelle des
loyers sur laquelle les parlementaires
travaillent et notamment les sénateurs
dans le cadre d'un groupe de travail qui
associe l'ensemble des familles
politiques de cet hémicycle sur le
dispositif qui repose sur un principe un
principe très simple qui est celui de la
solidarité et de la mise en oeuvre de
nos valeurs républicaines et qui repose
aussi sur trois objectifs le premier la
sécurisation des propriétaires un des
freins à la mise en location d'une
partie du parc privé le deuxième l'accès
au logement aujourd'hui on le sait les
jeunes notamment mais pas seulement les
personnes les plus précaires ont
d'extrêmes difficultés à accéder au
logement du fait des garanties
supplémentaires demandés par les
propriétaires et enfin le troisième un
sujet absolument décisif celui de la
prévention des expulsions la garantie
universelle c'est le résultat d'années
de réflexion et c'est aussi la suite de
travaux préalables des différentes
majorités le loca-pass puis le pass grl
puis la grl initié par le gouvernement
que vous souteniez et par mon
prédécesseur benoist apparu qui avait
d'ailleurs conclu lui même en réponse à
cette question que si ce dispositif
était insuffisant celui qui visait à
s'adresser plus particulièrement aux
salariés précaires il faudrait l'élargir
et l'universalité pour permettre de
sécuriser le parcours résidentiel c'est
ce chantier qui est engagée vous avez lu
partiellement une partie du rapport
doligé f mais son travail est
intéressant parce qu'il nous permet
justement d'identifier un certain nombre
de risques il permet aussi puis
désormais les choses donc son objectif
bien voir que le procès en sorcellerie
qui a été fait à l'égard de ce
dispositif est infondé puisque à partir
du moment où il sera robuste est bien
élaboré l'envolée des prix indiqués par
les uns et par les autres est totalement
inexact et ne correspond à aucune
réalité c'est bien donc vers un
dispositif robuste un dispositif socle
qui concernera l'ensemble des locataires
du parc privé mais aussi l'ensemble des
parts des propriétaires sur lequel nous
travaillons quant à son financement j'ai
dit déjà lors des débats parlementaires
que pour les raisons que vous pointez
notamment mais pour d'autres nous avions
abandonné l'idée d'une taxe même partagé
par les propriétaires et par les
locataires que nous travaillons sur
d'autres pistes de financement qu'elle
commence à évoluer et que étant donné
qu'aujourd'hui le budget si l'on
consacre l'ensemble des aides publiques
du logement en france avoisine les 40
milliards en les additionnant tous nous
pourront utilement travailler sur une
réaffectation pertinente de ceux ci
n'ayez donc aucune inquiétude sur la
mise en oeuvre de la garantie
universelle des loyers monsieur le
sénateur merci